(airy music)
- After 9-11, Sikhs become
target of hate crime,
and we felt a need to do
something at that point.
I thought: How can we interact
with other communities,
other people from different faiths
and educate people who Sikhs are?
We thought, well, let's
start a motorcycle group.
- My dad gives people a
point-of-view that is different.
That we aren't bad guys, we are good guys.
(airy music)
(motorcycle revving)
- [Narrator] The Sikh Riders
of America are a turban-wearing
motorcycle group that travels
the country educating people
about the Sikh religion.
The group was formed
in 2012, after a gunman
(chanting prayers)
entered a Sikh temple
and killed six people.
- The estimate is about 250,000 Sikhs living
in the United States.
There is a large portion
of our American neighbors
who doesn't know who the Sikhs are.
Sikh religion believes in equality to all
and then service to others.
I have experienced hate, just because
I'm a Sikh and I look different.
(motorcycles revving)
Riding a motorcycle is one
of the big American dream.
Sikhs are known warriors in India; we were
always riding horses,
and so motorcycles are
modern day horses,
that's one of the reasons
we wanted to start, so you
have something in common.
(inviting music)
- [Narrator] Each year, The
Sikh Riders of America put
on fundraisers to raise
money for local charities.
The fundraisers center
around leading community
motorcycle rides to local parks, where
in turn, people experience food, dance,
and traditions from Sikh culture.
And Gurinder is making sure to pass
his work down to the next generation.
- My son has been taking
a part in Sikh Riders
of America since he was 6 years old.
He has gone to homeless
shelters to feed the homeless.
I think it would be really
great if I'd be able
to pass it on to my son.
- Seeing my dad do those things makes
me feel proud of my dad.
(crowd cheering)
I think what my dad does for
the less fortunate inspires
me to do the same, so
I can follow his lead.
- It's everyone's event,
you're all a part of us
because without you, we
haven't been able to do it.
Thank you.
I personally have seen many people after
they met us, they learn about our religion
and who we are, they have changed
their view of looking at us.
We have made a big impact on
the communities we live in.
And we have been able to
educate people across America.
(finale music)